abone ol
e
Herkese merhabalar Bugün size bir
hikayeden bahsedeceğim bu hikaye Hem
benim bir noktada Hayal kırıklığında bir
nokta da aslında hepimizin
heyecanı duyabileceği bir hikaye
12000 yılında Dünya Genom Projesi İnsan
Genom Projesi açıklandığında ben o
sırada ilkokullar daydım
ve akşam Vaktiydi bu haberi aldığımda
çok üzülmüştüm insan günü açıklandı 3
milyar harfin Yani bizi her dönem bebek
yetişkinlik Hatta öldükten sonra bile
ifade edilen genlerimizin olduğu
bilindiği bir Genom kitabının
açıklandığı 2003 yılında duyurulmuştur
ve ben üzüldüm gerçekten de Çünkü şunu
söylemiştim ama Öyleyse benim
bulabileceğim başka bir şey kalmadı Ben
neyi tedavi edeceğim ben ne yapacağım
çünkü medya ve haberler
sanki Genom kitabının keşfedilmesi
açıklanmasının aslında bütün hikayenin
sonu olduğunu söylüyordu ama daha sonra
Anladık ki bu bir hikayenin sonu değil
aslında her şeyin başlangıcıydı bu O
İnsan Genom Projesi sadece bir ile iki
gibi sağlıklı insan gene onların
açıklanmasına dalıydı ve burada
haftalarca birçok dünya gazetesinde
Gündem olmuştu Ancak
son yapılan çalışmalarda 2003 yılında
toplam 13 gün süren ve 3 milyar dolara
mal olan İnsan Genom Projesi ni aslında
bütün İnsan genomunu açıklayamadığı bize
gösterdi yapılan çalışmalar bu de işimiz
birkaç ay önce yayınlandı
bıyığı yaklaşık yirmi yıl boyunca bizim
İnsan genomunda okuyamadığımız bazı
bölgeler olduğunu gösterdi Aslında 2003
yılında insan günü açıklandığında biz
genomun sadece yüzde 90 ikisinin
açıklana bildiğini görmüştük kitabın yüz
sayfalık kitabın halen 8 sayfası
Karanlıklar içerisindeydi geçen bu
içerisinde gelişen teknoloji
biyoenformatik
istatistik gibi teknolojiler bize Burada
gördüğünüz kırmızı Şehitler gibi
bölgelerinde açıklanmasına sebep oldu ve
böylelikle Biz 2022 yılında Yani benim
hayal kırıklığına uğradığım yıllardan
tam yirmi yıl sonra insan genomunun
tümünün yani Yüzde yüzünün açıklandığını
Artık bize gösteriyordu Ama bu ne
demiştim hikayenin sonu değil aslında
başlangıcıydı Çünkü insan genomunu
anlamak içerisindeki manaları ifadeleri
hastalıklar altında yatan sırları
anlayabilmek her şeyin sonu değildi Bir
de bu hastalıkları çözebilmek
binlerce hastalıktan muzdarip olan
Dünyada Milyonlarca insanın bir kere de
tedavi edilebilecek Genetik mühendislik
gibi teknolojileri kullanabilmek İşte
tam bulunduğumuz zamanın en verimli o
kadından the 2020 yılında Nobel kimya
ödülünü kazanan Emine açar painter ve
Jennifer Down a bakterilerde bulunan bir
Genetik mühendislik sisteminin bütün
canlıların genetiğini değiştirebilen bir
gözle görülmeyen moleküler robot haline
getirdikten sonra binlerce makale
yayınlandı yüzlerde canlının genetiği
değiştirildi binlerce patent alındı işte
Tam da bulunduğumuz bu zamanlarda biz
artık yüz sayfadan oluşan insan
görünümünü sadece anlamakla kalmıyor
sayfaların yerini değiştirebiliyoruz
kelimelerin yerini değiştirebiliyoruz
Bazen kelimeler içerisinde ünlü
düşüklüğü ya da anlam bozukluğu gibi
olduğu mutasyon dediğimiz genetik
bozuklukları artık halfar gözle
görülmeyen bir kitap içerisinde
değiştirebilecek hale geldik artık
genetiği değiştirilmiş insanlığa devrine
giriyorduk artık Pandora'nın Kutusu de
katıldığı bir dönemin gördük İşte geçen
2012 yılında çarpan tierwelt dağılmanın
kristal gen mühendisliği açıklamasından
hemen sonra yapılan birçok çalışmanın
sonunda artık
2017-2018 ve 2022 yılına kadar
geldiğimizde birçok insan genetiği
değiştirilmiş tedaviler almaya başladı
Burada gördüğünüz Buray madık daha
kristal çalışması çıkmadan Birkaç yıl
önce vücudunun içerisinde gel
mühendisliği yapıldı ve ciğer hücrelerin
genetiği değiştirildi ya da burada
gördüğümüz diğer hastamız veya gözünüzün
içerisine gözle görülmeyen mikro botlar
kristal gen mühendisliği yapılarak
enjekte edildi ve birçok canlıda artık
birçok insanda vücudumuza genetiğimizi
değiştirebilen robotlar girdi ve şuan Bu
çalışmalar gerçek zamanlı devam ediyor
Bu görüntü vermek istedim doktora
çalışmamın yok Üniversitesi'nde bu
Medical Center'da yapmıştım ve bu
çalışmada dünyada ilk kez
gerçekleştirildi en Valide lan Go
Medical Center'da gerçekleştirdi yine
Genetik mühendislik bizi ele geçirmeye
başlamıştı burada hepinizin bildiği gibi
organ nakli Aslında bizim çokça sıkıntı
çektiğimiz alanlardan biri özellikle
organ yetersizliği her yıl binlerce
insanın hayatının kaybolmasına sebep
olan çok trajik bir hastalık işte Son
yıllarda gerçekleştirilen Genetik
mühendislik atağı artık yapay organların
veya başka canlı da
yapay bir şekilde geliştirebilecek
organların insan vücuduna
aktarılabilecek bi bir dönemi başlattı
Burada gördüğünüz gibi biz buna
xenotransplantasyon diyoruz domuzun
yaklaşık Yirmi tane geni değiştirildi
Böylelikle Aslında insandan insana bile
nakilde özellikle doku uyuşmazlığı
sonunda çıkabilecek O da bir hastalık
sonucu gerçekleşen ölümü Biz domuzdan
bir insan hakları lan böbrekte veya
organda görmedik ha Neyse ki neyse gidin
çok üzücü bir şekilde hastamız hayatını
kaybetti geçtiğimiz bir iki hafta
içerisinde Bunun sebebi de domuzdaki bir
virüsün de tabii ki organ
transplantasyonu sonrasında hastaya
ulaşmasından dolayı Ama bu durum bile
genetiği değiştirilmiş veya tığı
askerlik dediğimiz hayvanlardan
organların insanlara aktarılabilecek
umudunu düşürmedi Bu bize gelecek
dönemde artık bir çok uzun doku
uyuşmazlığı olmadan yerinin
değiştirebileceği bir Devri de bize
gösterdi yani transhumanizm ve yakamın
2.0 artık 2.0 bir insan devrine
giriyorduk işte burada yapılan Genetik
mühendislik çalışmaları özellikle
pandemi döneminden geçen insanoğlunun
artık o karşılar gibi yıllarca
bekleyeceğiz tedaviler yerine çok kısa
bir süre içerisinde
tedavi edilebilecek gen mühendisliği
tarafından
potansiyel ilaçtan çıkmasını bize
sağlayacak bakteriyel viral veya
vücudumuzda bulunan 75 bin tane farklı
mutasyonu sebep olduğu 7130 tane
hastalığın çoğunun önüne geçebiliriz
genetik mühendislikle Yani önümüzdeki
yıllarda aramızda genetiği değiştirilmiş
geneti modifiye edilmiş Hatta genetiği
tamir edilmiş insanlar dolaşacak birçok
hastalıktan Kurtulmuş olarak şu ana
kadar yapılan gen tedavisi çalışmaları
binleri bulmuş durumda dünyanın çeşitli
yerlerinde birçok farklı genetik tedavi
yoluyla kanser tedavileri Nadir
hastalıkların tedavileri gerçekleştirmiş
bulunmakta Biz de özellikle Üsküdar
üniversitemizde bu tedavilerin
geleceğini gerçekleştirerek aslında bir
bakıma tır O bizim devrine
Hazırlanıyoruz
Peki bunlar her zaman toz pembe mi
Elbette değil 2016 yılında Çinli bir
bilim insanı Doktor hep dünyanın ilk
genetiği değiştirilmiş bebeklerini
duyulduğunda bütün dünya dondu kaldı iki
bebek dünyaya gelmişti na na ve Lulu
Aslında eşyayı yakalanması yani elbise
yakalanması muhtemel iki bebekti ve
bunda embriyo seviyesinde yaptığı crispr
gen mühendisliği sayesinde bu iki
bebeğine çay veya kalamayacağını ve
böylelikle Elsa hastalığına maruz
kalmayacağı bize göstermişti bu bir
bakıma Aslında Pandora'nın kutusunun
açıldığını ve bize yönettiği değiştirmiş
insanların yavaş yavaş aramızda
dolaşacağın söyledi tabi binlerce
dolarlık tazminatlar uzun bir süre
cezaevinde yaptıktan sonra Geçtiğimiz
aylarda dışarı çıkartıldı
bu ne kadar eleştirilse de aslında
birçok ülkenin perde arkasında
transhumanisme veya insan 2.0
hazırlandığını gösteriyordu aynı ülkede
geliştirilen veya amaçlanan diğer bir
çalışmadan 1'de süper askerler Biz
aslında süper askerler terimini Kanserde
kanseri mynote bize kullanırız kanserli
hastaların bağışıklık sistemi üzerine
alarak genetiğini değiştiririz ve şu
anda hayvan çalışmalarını yapıyoruz
üniversitemizde Böylelikle süper
askerler geliştirmeye çalışırız bunun
aynısını insan seviyesinde düşünün Çok
iyi düşünen hızlı karar veren güçlü ve
çok çabuk yorulmayan insanların
geliştirmesi Şu an bir yerlerde Kapalı
kapılar ardında planlanıyor işte bundan
dolayı her ne kadar kanser ve diğer
birçok hastalıkta umut verici
teknolojiler olmasına rağmen işte bu
gibi Aslında apokalips dediğimiz bizim
bambaşka bir devrin açılabileceği
kuşkusunu da göz çok seviyor artık kris
Fırla genetiği değiştirilmiş bebekler
dönemine girmeye başladık Yasak Olsa da
önümüzdeki yıllarda belki bambaşka
yerlerde böyle bebeklerin Belki de
üretilmesi Belki de geliştirmesi Mümkün
olabilir Burada gördüğünüz gibi Yapay
Zeka teknolojilerinde özellikle
birleştirmesi ile beraber artık bir
Doğum Hastanesi'nin hemen yan odasında
çok kısa bir süre içerisinde Genom
analizi yapılan embriyolarda hangi
bebeğin hangi dönemde meme kanserine
veya diğer birçok hastalığa
katılabileceği ve bunlar için crispr
reçetelerinin çıkabileceğini Böylelikle
Anne daha karnına bebek düşmeden tamir
edilip düşebileceği bir devrede girmiş
bulunuyoruz
bu 2045 yılında yani bundan tam yirmi
yıl sonra belki yine buralarda
buluşacağız Belki aramızda genetiği
değiştirilmiş insanlarda oturacak Big
biz Türkiye'de ilk Tıp tarihindeki gen
tedavileri yaptığımızda bir bakıma hayal
ettiğim de insanların gücü vücuduna
genetiği değiştirilmiş hücreler
veriyorduk yavaş yavaş insanlar
tedavilerinde kalıcı ve bölgede spesifik
tedavilerinde olabileceğini düşündüğümüz
de bir diğer taraftan insanların da
yenidoğa yapan demirlerden uzak bir
hayata kanser veya diğer birçok çeşit
hastalığa yakalanma the bir dünyaya
hazırlanıyor olabilirler Böylelikle
Belki de 20 yıl sonra gene muzun
yarısından çoğunun Genetik mühendislik
ve tamir edilebileceği ve ve
transhumanizm devrine girebileceğinizi
Hayal edebilirsiniz Arkadaşlar bu ara
artık yaşam bambaşka bir boyuta geldi
binlerce yıldır insan popülasyonu en
yeni bir Devri mm yılında atılmıştı biz
artık mm yılında İnsan Genom projesinde
ki o yüz sayfanın yerlerini bile
biliyorduk 2022 yılına geldiğimizde o
yüz sayfada özellikle karanlık Alanson 8
sayfayı da çözümledik bir bakıma artık
kitabın sonuna gelmiş bulunuyorduk Şimdi
artık Kitap okumak değil kitabı yazmak
kitabını anlamlarını öğrenmek kitabın
anlamlarını değiştirmek Belki de yeni
yaşamın 2.0 ını yazabilmek zamanı geldi
bunu iyi ellerde yapabilir kötü ellerde
yapabilir her zaman denetim içerisinde
olmasını düşünerek Aslında yeni bir
dünyanın kapısının yavaş yavaş
aralanıyor olacağını size söylemek
istedim beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim o